en contrebas du temple entouré de murs
protecteurs
le potager est le centre névralgique de
la communauté dans beaucoup de temple
même autrefois on
on a essayé d'être autonome parce que
bon les religieux en général ils sont
dépendants des subventions des dons des
gens et il y avait toujours dans
l'histoire dizaine des moments où les
mettre ils ont décidé de devenir
autonome une autonomie alimentaire qui
nécessite le soutien quotidien du
potager pour remund le jardin a une
importance cruciale dans sa pratique du
bouddhisme zen
j'ai commencé d'être jardinier en même
temps que j'ai commencé la pratique du
zen
donc ça m'a toujours accompagné ai dit
j'ai toujours essayé de transposer la
même concentration dans le jardinage
pour d'autres c'est la pratique de la
poterie traditionnelle japonaise qui les
a menés aux hazen non sans quelques
hésitations mais quand on connaît pas
c'est un peu bizarre ça ça nous
interpelle savez moi la base ça m'aurait
proposait même est en fait sur bout de
quelques jours on a un bien-être et on
se sent intégré dans un groupe on se
sent apaisé parce qu'on a un cadre on
est structuré on n'a pas besoin de
réfléchir à tous nos soucis de la vie
comme le quotidien la méditation et vu
aujourd'hui comme un remède au stress de
nos sociétés chercher l'apaisement dans
le zen c'est aussi ce qui attire les
nouveaux adeptes
mais pour les bouddhistes scène de la
première heure l'enjeu est ailleurs
souvent les gens quand ils pensent
méditation ils pensent mieux être et
pense bien être alors un petit peu de
spiritualité un peu de bien être un
petit peu de ceci un petit peu de cela
tout pour aller mieux mais tout ça c'est
une recherche généralement très égoïste
et dans la voie du bouddha c'est
abandonner cet égoïsme
c'est simplement s'asseoir et abandonner
les gosses
qu'on arrête de se la raconter on est au
coeur de l'expérience et la pratique du
zen c'est être au coeur de l'expérience
au coeur de l'astre un besoin de
spiritualité qui ne semble pas
s'éteindre le bouddhisme zen célébrer
l'année dernière ses 50 ans d'existence
en europe